awesome so happy to be here I'm going to
be telling you a little bit about
starting matter mark my company and so
let's jump right in about ten minutes
I'm Danielle Morrill on Twitter so tweet
to me if I don't tell you a story that
you want to hear and we'll keep going on
Twitter afterwards so just to jump right
in so how did I get to matter mark so
you know I was really excited to give
this talk because they were like tell
your life story so you know 1985 just
kidding all right so I did a bunch of
things before and the biggest thing that
I did that led me to build mater mark
was I actually dropped out of Community
College pretty early on and started
working in a shipping company shipping
companies are super interesting I know
there's some founders who've been here
talking about logistics today so when
you work as shipping you see all this
interesting data so we're going to come
back the data in a little bit ended up
getting into the startups teeing up in
Seattle publishing some stuff working on
a start-up there that ended up getting
acquired and then I moved to the Bay
Area right after the economy crashed in
2009 to work for Twilio when it was just
three founders and little me as a
marketing contractor ended up being the
first employee there did that for about
three and a half years and then started
a company called referral II that got
into Y Combinator to do social referrals
for products so kind of like affiliate
marketing for everyone turned out to be
a really crappy business 11 months in
negative gross margins which we now know
from the startup press or bad thing
restarted the company entirely as a
matter mark and that's what I'm going to
tell you about today so through Y
Combinator we're shutting down refer lee
so of course I went to Paul Graham and I
wanted some advice instead you know I'm
really burned out this business is not
working and right now I'm also kind of
just disillusioned about Silicon Valley
and I really of all the things that I
dislike you know they say find that
thing that drives you crazy in that
world the problem that you want to solve
really hate TechCrunch yeah I've written
this before don't worry it's not news
they know
and so I really hate it because it
doesn't cover the startup so my friends
are working on and it doesn't really
feel like I'm connected to it it feels
like it's like Google Apple Microsoft
Nokia Yahoo whatever it's like well you
know most of my friends are building
startups that are like three people in
an apartment so pg was like well if you
want to kill TechCrunch then do that so
really like that's probably not gonna be
a very good business so could it be a
good business could it have traction I
honestly didn't worry about that at
first I was like I just want to do
something I like because I'm really
worried I'm gonna get jaded and I'm
gonna get out of this town and I'm never
going to come back so I decided okay
over 30 days what I'm going to do is I'm
going to write a blog post every day I
can I live like this can I actually
publish every day do I have any right to
say anything negative about these
journalists turns out it's really hard
really hard to publish every day not
only that but I'm not a journalist or
wasn't then I'm not sure what I am but
we had a couple posts that really took
off we wrote a post about zombie
startups we wrote including ourselves we
wrote a post about zombie VCS where we
took a bunch of data from crunch base
and tried to show which VCS were talking
a big game but not actually actively
investing in startups and pissed off
everybody in the industry it was awesome
so the first lesson there was if you
piss off everybody you might have
something because people don't get
pissed off about a lot of things they're
usually just ambivalent so that was very
interesting and it validated that we
could build an audience you know
TechCrunch has an audience we could
build an audience
we liked data because we didn't have any
leads we didn't have any relationships
we didn't have any sources and no PR
people were sending us any pitches so
some of the posts that were successful
gave us a sense of the type of stuff
that might work and we got this really
encouraging email so at one point we
indexed or we listed all the companies
in the andreessen horowitz portfolio and
we rank them based on some growth
metrics we were tracking and I got this
email from Marc Andreessen who I'd never
met and it was like yeah what that guy
said holy we should be doing this
ourselves that's what he said with the
smiley face is copy-pasted sorry
I swear and I thought I was like okay
well holy
why aren't they doing this right like it
must be there must be some reason and it
turns out it's hard it's time-consuming
there's a lot of stuff to do at a VC
firm we knew nothing about that at the
time we need nothing about venture
capital people think oh well they were
always VC insiders that's why they
started this business no definitely not
insiders so we published some of our
research and the data at the bottom of
our blog posts so people started
emailing us saying can we get more of
those spreadsheets and then they would
have one for a while and they would say
can we get an update we were like you
know sure why not
here's the update and at some point
there's just so many spreadsheets and so
many updates that my husband my CTO was
like we should probably you know like
build software for this maybe like you
know make it simple to log in so finding
and analyzing data is hard that's what
you realize so let's build this little
database so turns out you can take a my
sequel database you can shove it into a
really stupid simple JavaScript library
and you have a really ugly ass database
that people can log into and you don't
have to worry about you know a sign-in
system just some litte T access and
everybody's logging into the same damn
thing and that's what we had it's really
simple and for those of you don't know
what some of that stuff is it doesn't
matter because it was so simple that I
could set it up without even necessarily
being very good at writing code so now
we have these spreadsheets you have
these lists we had about 20,000 startups
we were tracking and you guys can
probably imagine there's way more than
20,000 companies out there and it's me
my husband Kevin our CTO and my best
friend Andy living in this tiny
apartment in San Francisco and Andy's
the data monkey literally I would come
up with a post idea and I'd be like okay
you've got 48 hours to get all the data
will I write the other post and then
Andy would go and get all the data and I
write the post and do a document how I
did it and then Kevin would write the
software so that he never had to do it
again and then we just did that over and
over and over again people thought we
had magic but we didn't have magic yet
and then something really crazy happened
and this is definitely where we got
lucky so Lina Rao who I believe now
writes at fortune was writing for
TechCrunch at the time and TechCrunch
wrote a trend piece about quantitative
venture capital this is in the summer of
2013 and at the very end of the post she
said maybe some smart startup will come
along and solve this problem so the post
goes out on a Friday I read this post
I'm in Palo Alto I think trying to sell
to someone and I pull over and I call up
my co-founders I'm like oh my god we
have to jump on this now she just told
the whole valley to build this and we're
building it how like how do I get her
phone number so you know imagine tapping
around on Facebook and Twitter and
whatever and call her and say okay we're
building this thing let me show you what
we made we want to launch on Monday and
we all we had was that thing we showed
you before that little ugly spreadsheet
in yellow with a little like single user
login and we had no marketing page we
had no login system we had no user
system nothing she's a great I'd love to
launch you exclusively on Monday so we
were like okay cool we were moving into
a new apartment that weekend we were all
sick so we built the rest of the product
so when we launched and it was free some
people could sign up these were leads
also oh I never really done B to be
before or SAS so we were like Oh weeds
what's that so we're on TechCrunch it's
amazing you know back by any and
Andreessen by the way I think Andreessen
wrote us a $50,000 check when our bank
account was at its lowest so it doesn't
matter it's a really nice headline we
got this thing out there and we had some
early customers so that was how we built
the prototype how do we get the early
customers well honestly we just
contacted every single venture capital
firm NEA was already an investor so that
was really helpful they offered us an
enterprise contract right out of the
gate and then Albert Vanguard and Square
Ventures is a data nerd he loves
consuming api's gave him access he wrote
an amazing blog post
um and these are surprises we just wake
up and and there's this blog post from
him talking about how every VC of the
future is going to need to use data and
we're just like not really sure this is
all really happening and the funniest
thing was we launched with this tagline
the matter mark was like a bloomberg for
startups and Bloomberg actually launched
a venture capital fund the same day so
that was weird so we obviously needed to
connect with them and then we ended up
doing a research project with them I'll
never forget Roy telling me hey you
should really take our $50,000 because
it's the best capital you'll ever take
it's not diluted and I was like oh maybe
I could get someone else to give me
$50,000 that's not diluted I mean we
didn't know anything about b2b we had
been making like $1 37 at a time on
affiliate marketing for the past two
years so it was it was a lot better so
then we realized we've got to go and
sell all the VCS we've got to do it as
fast as possible we've got to go down
Sand Hill Road and over the next three
weeks we just tried to meet with
everyone we could it's funny it was
actually easier to get meetings for
selling them something than pitching
them very much I guess not very many
people are trying to sell things to VC's
I don't know but it was really weird
it's like suddenly I'm in these
boardrooms that I could never get into
before you know Sequoia and Google
Ventures and I'm like okay this is I'm
on the other side what side am I on
I don't really know and we're learning
how venture capital works so literally
sit me down with an associate and tell
me what's hard about your job why are
you wasting time you've got an MBA from
Harvard you probably don't need to be a
data monkey and setting them free from
that so we had all this validation and
we decided we better start charging
money for this also we're going to be
broke because we're all living in an
apartment together and we only had like
$150,000 of the million we'd raised left
which was only gonna last us like six or
seven more months so we launched matter
mark Pro for $499 a month and the way
that happened is Albert from USD who I
mentioned before basically I was on the
phone doing like a discovery call making
sure things were going well and he said
I feel kind of guilty you're not
charging me
I was like okay so should I charge you
it's like yeah how much is it okay um
I'm thinking to myself my expense
reporting policy in my last job was oh
yeah
$4.99 because $500 is where you have to
get approval um that was the logic so
really good way to price your product so
he was like great where do I put my
credit card um let me call you back
this is also he's on the East Coast so
it's like 8:30 in the morning I run over
to Kevin wake him up
you got to build a stripe form right now
what ah what get up get up they want to
give us money oh can it wait no I can't
wait you're kidding me like I can't wait
besides stripe is amazing so we had 25
minutes later because he's awesome
we had a stripe form up and I call him
back sorry I didn't know the URL here's
the page totally have it together and
then they paid us like so that was the
beginning of the addiction to SAS so
then we had money in the bank we got
twelve paying customers something close
to that
$4.99 times whatever in the first month
and three years later where it were
actually at three point five million and
air are now so we make about just shy of
three hundred thousand dollars a month
so that's what happened and it was a
little bit crazy and it's so crazy in
fact because we were going a lot bigger
with Matt or mark today than before we
don't just sell the VCS anymore now we
realize sales teams have the exact same
problem VC's do so now we're in the
process of figuring out how to track
every company in the world which is
going to be hopefully another set of
crazy stories that I'll get to come back
and tell you the next conference so I'm
out of time and I'd love to answer to
questions but thank you for hearing the
beginning of my life story
I think we have time for two questions
really good job with the clicker by the
way kill it thank you any questions
yeah thank you
follow me on Twitter
yeah so the question is are we pivoting
away from venture capital kind of how do
we see the balance of serving the VC
customers and news aggregation so news
aggregation is awesome so we have a
newsletter called the matter mark daily
it goes out every day to about a hundred
thousand people highly recommend you
subscribe on our website and it tries to
aggregate the best of the content that
comes from the VCS and the best of the
content that comes from start-up
operators and really importantly we
really look for those editorial column
style pieces where you're telling your
own experience because that's what I
wanted and ideally in a dream world I'd
write all those stories so I think we'll
continue to do that primarily because it
comes from a place of passion and it's
how we build our community we now do
crawl the majority of the internet for
news and so we do our technology pulls
facts out of news and organizes them
into a database so that turns out to be
really valuable for lots of purposes but
over the long term our business will
probably become less focused on venture
capital just because it's only a you
know maybe 20 to 50 million dollar a
year revenue business if we get every
single drop of it whereas if you solve
the problems for sales people it's a
much bigger market so I think I don't
like to think of it as a pivot we still
love those initial customers it's just a
realization that to really be as big of
business as we want to be we've got to
keep expanding hey hey Danielle
my name is Brian I'm curious what some
of the non-intuitive signals you found
where they indicate that a start-up is
on to something non-intuitive well now I
feel like they're obvious but there
probably weren't intuitive so I think
early employee count is is very
important um kind of net employee count
so you're turning people over they're
leaving and coming but is the graph
ultimately up in to the right and how
fast is that growing now I hesitate to
say it's not an intuitive because when I
say it you're probably like well duh
like you don't hire more people to into
your startup until things feel like
they're going well but it turns out
that's a really hard thing to track so
it has been a really valuable data point
that we track really well I think I have
time for one more
another I don't have a question
I just want to say you are a total
badass Thanks total badass and okay so I
was actually the sponsor t-shirts matter
but Reid Hoffman who I used to work with
he was my manager he's got this really
famous phrase if you're not embarrassed
by your first product watch then you've
launched too late why I watch the way I
supposed to have a table okay i paper
table i can get my together
anyways on bear anyways for every single
speaker everyone will get a free t-shirt
because i have a database that's hustle
and then everyone gets 10% off once i
get my off in front so there's that
oh and then okay I'm an investor I'm an
angel investor in hustle con media and I
sent an email to 100 people
I didn't BCC him including Sarah Lacy
and she replied back that it was
inconsiderate and then sampark basically
my what's your business good luck thank
you very much - thank you everyone all
right